The year is 1783. The Revolutionary War is ending, the fighting on American soil, finally tapering off. But what does it actually mean to be an American? If you ask anyone this question at the time, they more than likely wouldn't have a clear answer. Regular life is still chaotic. Classrooms, if they exist at all, are under-resourced, and the books students are using aren't even American. They're British, teaching British geography, British history, British ways of thinking. People are still spelling the word color with a you. One ambitious
时年1783。独立战争即将结束，美国本土上的战火终于渐渐平息。但作为一个美国人究竟意味着什么？如果你当时向任何人提出这个问题，他们多半无法给出清晰的答案。日常生活依然混乱。学校（如果它们真的存在的话）资源匮乏，学生们使用的课本甚至都不是美国的。它们是英国的，教授的是英国地理、英国历史、英国的思维方式。人们还在用带字母u的拼法来拼color这个词。一位雄心勃勃的
school teacher looks around at all of this and decides this has to change. His name is Noah Webster. Noah Webster is fascinating because he's this person who takes on as an educator the problem of literacy. That's Amani Perry, author and professor of African American Studies at Harvard University. And he complains about the classrooms being crowded and noisy and chaotic, and he is also sort of interested in trying to find a way to standardize American learning. Webster saw how inconsistent education was, no standard curriculum, no shared set of books or processes. He thought we needed a system. So long before his dictionary made him a household name, Webster spends his own money to print a little blue book with an unconstitutional. unwieldy title. It's called the first part of the grammatical institute of the English language,
学校老师环顾这一切，认为必须做出改变。他的名字叫诺亚·韦伯斯特。诺亚·韦伯斯特非常迷人，因为他是作为一名教育家勇敢承担起扫盲问题的人。这是哈佛大学非洲美国研究教授兼作家阿马尼·佩里的话。他抱怨教室拥挤、嘈杂、混乱，同时他也对尝试寻找一种标准化美国学习的方法很感兴趣。韦伯斯特看到了教育是多么缺乏一致性，没有标准的课程，没有共享的书籍或流程。他认为我们需要一个体制。因此，早在他的词典让他家喻户晓的很久之前，韦伯斯特就自掏腰包印刷了一本带有违反常理的笨重标题的小蓝书。它被称为《英文语法研究所第一部分》，
a title so bad that nobody ever used it. They just started calling it, the blueback speller. So he really creates this book that is built for an autodidact. It's a way to self-teach literacy. He writes the blueback speller for people to teach themselves to read or to aid teachers who are teaching students to read, You know, he really is a kind of key figure in American letters. The idea that you would learn to read through reading is a leap. You know what I mean to teach yourself? How to read? How to read?
这个书名太糟糕了，以至于根本没人用它。人们开始简单地叫它“蓝皮拼写书”。所以他确实创作了这本专为自学者打造的书。这是一种自学识字的方法。他写这本蓝皮拼写书是为了让人门自学阅读，或者是为了辅助老师教学生阅读，你知道的，他确实是美国文学界的一个关键人物。通过阅读来学习阅读这个想法是一个飞跃。你知道我的意思吗，自学？如何阅读？怎么阅读？
So I have a copy with me. Could you describe it for me, though? Like, what does it do? What does it look like? How is it not a dictionary that's describe its use? Yeah, it has some sort of basic phonetic lessons, entry points of pronunciation, short words, And then in the midst of it, this sort of moral lessons written. So it really is like a guide to learning to read and the way that later generations, you know, we had books like Hop on Pop.
所以我随身带了一本。不过你能帮我描述一下吗？比如，它有什么用？它长什么样？它怎么就不是一本词典了，描述一下它的用途吧。是的，它有一些基本的语音课程、发音切入点、短词，然后在其中穿插了一些道德课程。所以它确实就像是一本学习阅读的指南，就像后来的几代人，你知道的，我们有像《戴帽子的猫》（译者注：原文为Hop on Pop，即苏斯博士的书）这样的书。
But in that period, it was the closest thing. And there's so many of them still around because there were so many printed once upon a time. Within a few years, the blue backspeller becomes one of the most widely used school books in the country. entire generations grew up with it. Even Abraham Lincoln learned to read from its pages. It taught literacy, yes, but it was also shaping a new American language in identity. Webster uses the book to introduce simpler, more distinctly American spellings. He drops the U from humor and labor.
但在那个时期，它是最接近这种类型的书了。现在市面上依然有很多这样的书，因为曾经印数极多。短短几年内，这本蓝皮拼写书就成了全国使用最广泛的学校课本之一。整整好几代人都是伴随着它长大的。甚至亚伯拉罕·林肯也是从它的书页中学会阅读的。它传授了识字能力，没错，但它也在塑造一种新的美国语言和身份。韦伯斯特利用这本书引入了更简单、更具美国特色的拼写。他去掉了humor和labor中的字母u。
Music and politics lose the extra K. He once suggested that we start spelling daughter as D-A-W-T-E-R, which would have been nice, though that one didn't stick. but his larger idea does succeed. At one point, the blue backspeller was second only to the Bible in copies sold. And it also is kind of like a Bible. Like there's these tools and lessons built into it. Could you describe its size and the relevance of its size? Yeah.
Music和politics去掉了多余的k。他曾经建议我们将daughter拼作D-A-W-T-E-R，这本来会挺不错的，尽管那个拼法没有流行开来。但他更大的构想成功了。一度，这本蓝皮拼写书的销量仅次于《圣经》。而且它某种程度上也确实像一本圣经。就像其中内置了各种工具和课程一样。你能描述一下它的尺寸以及其尺寸的重要性吗？是的。
I mean, it's wonderful to hold one because you realize it's pocket size. I mean, it was small enough to carry. The blueback speller could be carried with you wherever you wanted to go. literally fit into a jacket pocket or pants pocket or a small satchel. And so it was mobile. It was a tool that traveled with people. Yeah. And it could be hidden.
我的意思是，拿在手里感觉很奇妙，因为你会发现它是口袋尺寸的。我是说，它小得足以随身携带。这本蓝皮拼写书可以随身携带，无论你想去哪里。它简直可以塞进夹克口袋、裤兜或者一个小斜挎包里。所以它是可移动的。它是一个伴随人们出行的工具。是的。而且它可以被藏起来。
It could easily be hidden, which was really important. Important because it means the book could be used secretly by people who weren't supposed to have it. Enslaved people who are legally prohibited from learning to read. People, Amani says, that Webster. never intended this book for at all. Noah Webster is really trying to create an American identity that's based upon this notion of American democracy. He has this conception of what it means to be American that does not include black people in any measure. And that's evidence throughout his work. And despite that
它很容易被藏起来，这真的很重要。重要是因为这意味着这本书可以被那些不被允许拥有它的人秘密使用。那些在法律上被禁止学习识字的被奴役的人。阿马尼说，这些人正是韦伯斯特从未打算为之写这本书的人。诺亚·韦伯斯特确实在努力创造一种基于美国民主概念的美国身份。他对做美国人意味着什么有着这样的构想，其中根本不包含黑人。这在他的作品中处处都有证据。尽管有这个
fact, his blueback speller becomes something that is fundamental to African-American struggles for literacy. From 99% Invisible and BBC Studios, this is a history of the United States in 100 Objects. I'm Roman Mars. Today, the Webster blew back speller, how Black Americans transformed a schoolbook not meant for them into a tool for their liberation, and how that little book became the foundation for a historic debate around what education is for and what it means to be free. Before emancipation, in much of the slaveholding South, learning to read as an enslaved person, came with brutal consequences. But the blueback speller was everywhere, so common that some enslaved people managed to get their hands on it anyway.
事实，他的蓝皮拼写书却成为了非洲裔美国人争取识字斗争的基石。来自“99%隐形”与BBC工作室，这里是《用100件物品讲述美国历史》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。今天的主角是韦伯斯特蓝皮拼写书，看美国黑人如何将一本原本不属于他们的学校课本转变为他们争取解放的工具，以及这本小书如何成为围绕教育的用途和自由的含义展开历史性辩论的基础。在废除奴隶制之前，在蓄奴盛行的美国南部大部分地区，作为一个被奴役的人学习识字会带来残酷的后果。但这本蓝皮拼写书无处不在，实在太常见了，以至于一些被奴役的人无论如何还是设法弄到了它。
People like Frederick Douglass. Part of what is powerful about it is if we think about someone like Frederick Douglass who is enslaved and fundamentally teaches himself to read, using the blueback speller. Douglas would go on to become one of the most influential writers and thinkers in American history. He'd become an advisor to Abraham Lincoln. But when he first encounters the blueback speller, he's still enslaved. And learning to read is dangerous. In the context of enslavement,
像弗雷德里克·道格拉斯这样的人。它之所以充满力量，部分原因在于，如果我们想到像弗雷德里克·道格拉斯这样被奴役且从根本上靠自己学会阅读的人，他使用了这本蓝皮拼写书。道格拉斯后来成为了美国历史上最有影响力的作家和思想家之一。他将成为亚伯拉罕·林肯的顾问。但当他第一次接触到这本蓝皮拼写书时，他仍然是一名奴隶。而学习识字是危险的。在被奴役的语境下，
having one of these spellers for someone who's enslaved could put you at enormous risk of maiming, of death, of being sold. And if we know that here's Noah Webster who created this, he's someone who doesn't consider a person like Douglas as part of the American body, right, of not part of the relevant community of who Americans are. Noah Webster opposed the institution of slavery. But even still, the idea that this book was for Americans meant it inherently excluded enslaved people from its intended readership.
对于一个被奴役的人来说，拥有这样一本拼写书会让你面临巨大的风险：致残、死亡、被卖掉。如果我们知道诺亚·韦伯斯特创造了这一切，而他却是一个不把道格拉斯这样的人视为美国主体一部分的人，对吧，不属于美国人相关社群的一部分。诺亚·韦伯斯特反对奴隶制。但即便如此，这本书是为美国人准备的这个想法，意味着它天生地将受奴役的人排除在了其预期的读者群之外。
And yet Douglas teaches himself, and through teaching himself, frees himself. And he and countless other black people take on that blue-back speller and insist upon becoming part of the literate American public, irrespective of what Noah Webster thought of black people or intended. And that is this remarkable kind of motif through African-American history of existing in the terms of the United States understanding, being marginal and excluded, and fighting to be recognized as part of that public,
然而道格拉斯自学成才，并透过自学解放了自己。他和无数其他黑人拿起了这本蓝皮拼写书，坚持要成为识字的美国公众的一部分，无论诺亚·韦伯斯特对黑人持什么看法或意图如何。这正是非洲裔美国人历史中那种非凡的主题：在不符合美国理解的条件下存在，处于边缘和被排除在外，却为争取被认可为该公众的一部分而抗争，
sometimes at great risk. So this drive for literacy was a kind of remarkable passion and conviction to be free in ways that you might not be free in body, but you could be free in mind. So the blueback speller offered a kind of mental survival during slavery. Then emancipation comes. And suddenly, education isn't just about being free in the mind anymore. So how does this little blue book change what comes next? Like, what does it represent after emancipation? Yeah, I mean, so we know that one of the first things that the formerly enslaved
有时甚至冒着极大的风险。因此，这种对识字的追求是一种非凡的激情与信念，要在肉体可能不自由的方面去获得自由，但你的精神可以自由。所以蓝皮拼写书在奴隶制时期提供了一种精神上的生存方式。然后奴隶制被废除了。突然之间，教育不仅仅再关乎精神上的自由了。那么这本小蓝书是如何改变接下来的事态的呢？比如，它在废奴之后代表着什么？是的，我的意思是，我们知道前奴隶们
that the freed people wanted to do was to go to school or to be educated. And one of the early ways we see this is black soldiers in the Civil War who become literate and immediately begin writing letters to Lincoln saying not only are they hopeful for land with their freedom, but there have to be schools. We see it in the contraband camps in the Civil War where there are even photographs of people holding blueback spellers of black people who have fled behind union lines and are learning to read in the midst of battlefields. And then after emancipation, these schools that open up, there are students. who range from, you know, tiny children to octogenarians, just passionate for literacy.
也就是获得自由的人们想做的第一件事就是去上学或接受教育。我们看到这一点的早期途径之一是南北战争中的黑人士兵，他们识字了，并立即开始给林肯写信，不仅说他们对随着自由而来的土地充满希望，而且必须有学校。我们在内战时期的违禁品营地中看到了这一点，那里甚至有照片记录着人们拿着蓝皮拼写书，那些逃到联邦军队防线后方并在战火中学习识字的黑人。在废奴之后，这些学校开放了，学生们
And this is, of course, because literacy is tied to freedom because the idea was that literacy made someone unfit to be a slave. And so then to be free necessarily meant to become literate. And so you can imagine that on a day-to-day basis, even with these new rights, the very idea of black people reading was threatening to many white Southerners. And so at the same time as there's this passion for education, there was also this sense of danger. And perhaps the most dramatic example of this is how frequently schools that served African-Americans were burned to the ground. So there were school fires constantly. And it's just a symbol of how on the one hand there's this passion for education and on the other there's this incredible sense of threat for many to the project of black schooling. And so the blueback speller is something that became a particularly prized possession because it meant that even if one wasn't in a classroom, you could still continue to pursue the lessons of literacy.
年龄跨度从牙牙学童到八旬老人不等，对识字充满热情。当然，这是因为识字与自由息息相关，当时的观点是识字使一个人不再适合做奴隶。因此，获得自由必然意味着变得识字。所以你可以想象，在日常生活中，即便有了这些新权利，黑人读书的这个想法本身对许多南方白人来说也是一种威胁。因此，在对教育充满热情的同一时期，也伴随着一种危险感。也许最戏剧性的例子就是为非洲裔美国人服务的学校被烧为平地的频率有多高。所以学校火灾不断发生。这正是一个象征：一方面是对教育的热情，另一方面对于许多人来说，黑人办学的事业带来了难以置信的威胁感。因此，蓝皮拼写书成了一件特别珍贵的财产，因为这意味着即使不在教室里，你仍然可以继续追求识字的课程。
You know, so people carried them around with them, almost like amulets from working all day and then reading it by candlelight at night or taking breaks from the field. And so it had this sort of almost mystical quality to it. This mystical book would play a transformative role in the lives of many black Americans. But the reason we wanted to focus on the speller was because the profound impact this book would have on two of the most powerful black men in American history. Two men who become fierce rivals and whose disagreement essentially split the black intellectual world into. Booker T. Washington and W.E.B. Du Bois. Their rivalry wasn't personal. It was a battle over the most urgent question in America. What does freedom actually mean? And how do you fight for it? Do you demand everything right now, or do you work within the system, inch by inch, and wait for your moment? Through their encounters with the blueback speller and the very different lessons each man took from it,
你知道的，所以人们随身携带它们，几乎就像护身符一样，从一整天的劳作后在夜间靠烛光阅读，或是从农田劳作中抽空阅读。所以它几乎具有某种神秘的特质。这本神秘的书将在许多美国黑人的生活中扮演变革性的角色。但我们想要聚焦于这本拼写书的原因，是因为这本书对美国历史上两位最有权势的黑人产生深远的影响。两个后来成为死敌的人，他们的分歧从根本上将黑人知识界分裂为二：布克·T·华盛顿和W·E·B·杜波依斯。他们的竞争不是私人的。这是一场关于美国最紧迫问题的较量。自由究竟意味着什么？你又该如何为之抗争？你是要求现在就拥有一切，还是在体制内一步一个脚印地努力，等待属于你的时刻？通过他们与蓝皮拼写书的相遇以及两人从中汲取的截然不同的经验，
you can trace the fault lines of a debate that is still very much alive today. Let's start with Booker T. Washington. He was born into slavery and later freed when news of emancipation reached the plantation where he and his family were held. All Booker wants is to learn to read. But instead he has to work in a salt mine to help support his family. To make matters worse, he could see and hear happy children passing to and from school mornings and afternoons from where he was working in the minds. So he asks his mother for help. His mother got her hands on a blueback speller for him, and he treated it as a kind of magical document.
你可以追溯到今天依然十分活跃的这场辩论的断层线。让我们从布克·T·华盛顿开始。他出生于奴隶制家庭，后来当他和他家人被关押的种植园收到废奴消息时重获自由。布克想要的全部就是学习阅读。但他却不得不去盐矿工作以帮补家用。更糟糕的是，从他在矿里工作的地方，他可以看到并听到快乐的孩子们在早晨和下午上学放学的路上走过。于是他向母亲寻求帮助。他的母亲为他弄到了一本蓝皮拼写书，他把它当成了一种神奇的文件。
He taught himself to read with it, and it really shaped his life. This is the very first book that Booker holds in his hand, and it changes the course of his life. There's this trajectory from his mother finding this book for him, and he thinking that this is sort of the greatest possible, you know, object that he could have, and then becoming ultimately the most powerful black man in the United States. After teaching himself to read using the blueback speller, he attends night school, after working in the salt mines all day. Then in 1872, at age 16, he makes his way to Hampton Institute,
他用它自学了阅读，这确实塑造了他的生活。这是布克手中拿的第一本书，它改变了他的人生轨迹。这里有一个轨迹：从他的母亲为他找到这本书，到他认为这是他所能拥有的某种可能的最伟大的物品，再到最终成为美国最有权势的黑人。在使用蓝皮拼写书自学阅读后，他在一整天矿工劳作之余去上夜校。然后在1872年，16岁时，他动身前往汉普顿学院，
which is one of the first schools established for African Americans in Virginia. He has to walk, I think it's something like 500 miles to get to Hampton Institute. You know, so this passion, this drive for education is extraordinary. And then he becomes the first principal and then later on what would be president of Tuskegee Institute, now Tuskegee University. On the 4th of July of 1881, Washington arrived at Tuskegee as its first principal. But the school existed in name only. The state of Alabama had allocated just $2,000 a year to pay the teachers.
这是弗吉尼亚州最早为非洲裔美国人设立的学校之一。我想他步行了大约500英里才到达汉普顿学院。你知道的，所以这种激情、对教育的渴望是非凡的。后来他成为了塔斯基吉学院（现为塔斯基吉大学）的第一任校长，后来又成为了所谓的院长。1881年7月4日，华盛顿作为首任校长抵达塔斯基吉。但这所学校只是名存实亡。阿拉巴马州每年只拨款2000美元来支付教师薪水。
There was no land, no buildings, no equipment, just some cash, and an idea on paper. So Washington shows up and just starts teaching. At first, out of a one-room shanty. It was in such disrepair that whenever it rained, one of the students would have to hold an umbrella over Washington's head for the rest of the lesson. Shortly after that, Washington borrows some money to buy an abandoned 100-acre former plantation, and he and his students build Tuskegee with their own hands, brick by brick. As in, they literally make the bricks themselves. But it isn't easy. The first brick kiln fails, then the second, then the third. At one point,
没有土地，没有建筑，没有设备，只有一些现金和纸上的一段构想。于是华盛顿出现并直接开始教学。起初是在一个单间棚屋里。那里破败不堪，每当下雨时，其中一个学生就得在华盛顿头顶撑一把伞来上完剩下的课。不久之后，华盛顿借了一些钱买下了一个废弃的占地100英亩的前种植园，他和他的学生们用自己的双手，一块砖一块砖地建造了塔斯基吉。正如字面意思，他们亲手制作了砖块。但这并不容易。第一个砖窑失败了，然后是第二个，接着是第三个。有那么一刻，
he pawns his watch for $15 just to keep the experiment going. For Washington, it's a lesson in the dignity of labor. And it gets to his core idea about education. Instead of teaching the humanities, he thought education should be focused on giving black people practical skills, a philosophy known as industrial education. So Tuskegee becomes this institution through the leadership of Booker T. Washington that is a model of industrial education.
他把自己的手表当了15美元，只为了让这个试验继续下去。对华盛顿来说，这是关于劳动尊严的一课。这切中了他关于教育的核心理念。他认为教育不应该教授人文学科，而应该专注于赋予黑人实际的技能，这一哲学被称为实业教育。因此，在布克·T·华盛顿的领导下，塔斯基吉成为了实业教育的典范。
So engineering, animal husband, agricultural work and the like. Things like learning how to build porches, appropriate ventilation for housing, how do you grow crops to appropriately feed the community? How do you take care of the land? Not everyone agreed that these were the most important things to be learning. For many black families, it felt like settling.
比如工程学、畜牧业、农业工作等等。诸如学习如何建造门廊、房屋的适当通风、如何种植农作物以适当地喂饱社区？如何照顾土地？并非所有人都同意这些是最重要的学习内容。对于许多黑人家庭来说，这感觉像是妥协。
After generations of being denied literacy, why not go all in on classical education? Why not Latin, philosophy? literature, everything that had been kept out of reach for so long. But Washington was also thinking strategically. In a country still shaped by Jim Crow, where reconstruction efforts had failed and been abandoned, he believed pushing for industrial education was more likely to be tolerated, less likely to provoke backlash.
在历经几代人被剥夺识字权之后，为什么不全力投入古典教育呢？为什么不学拉丁语、哲学、文学，去学那些长期以来被拒之门外的一切呢？但华盛顿也在进行战略性思考。在一个依然受吉姆·克劳法影响、重建努力已经失败并被放弃的国家，他相信推动实业教育更有可能被容忍，也更不容易激起强烈反弹。
Industrial education was conceived of as less threatening in many ways than classical education for black Americans because classical education was well. the most elite white Americans, that kind of education they received. Booker T. Washington was advocating for this education that keeps people working in relationship to the land, right? That's part of why it's seen as less threatening. Underneath that educational philosophy, there was a more controversial political idea. Washington believed that economic self-sufficiency had to come before the push for full civil rights. He did not believe in immediately pressing
在许多方面，实业教育被认为比古典教育对美国黑人的威胁要小，因为古典教育嘛，那是最高阶的白人美国人才会接受的那种教育。布克·T·华盛顿所倡导的是一种让人保持与土地联系并进行劳动的教育，对吧？这也是它被视为威胁较小的原因之一。在那套教育哲学之下，隐藏着一个更具争议的政治理念。华盛顿认为，经济上的自给自足必须先于对全面民权的争取。他并不相信应该立即去争取
for access to suffrage and other kinds of civil rights for African Americans and instead focused on economic development, land acquisition, and the like. And this philosophy? This philosophy was about to make him one of the most famous men in America. And the thing that would do it was a single speech delivered on a single afternoon in Atlanta in 1895. The city was hosting a World's Fair and had invited Booker T. Washington, to speak. By then, Washington had become a rare figure, a black leader that Southerners felt comfortable with, comfortable enough to put him on stage. Picture it. The late afternoon's sun is pouring into his eyes as he steps to the podium. Gilmore's band plays the star-spangled
获得选举权以及非洲裔美国人的其他各类民权，而是专注于经济发展、土地收购等。而这套哲学？这套哲学即将让他成为美国最著名的人物之一。而促成这一切的是1895年在亚特兰大一个下午发表的一场演讲。该市正在举办世界博览会，并邀请了布克·T·华盛顿前去演讲。到那时，华盛顿已成为一个罕见的人物，一个让南方人感到自在的黑人领袖，自在到足以把他推上舞台。想象一下。下午晚些时候的阳光直射进他的眼睛，他走上讲台。吉尔摩乐队演奏了《星条旗》，
banner, and then Dixie. Thousands are staring at this black man about to address a white southern audience on a national stage, something that had likely never happened to. before in that part of the country. This famous or infamous speech that he delivers in 1895, in which he says that black and white Americans can be as separate as fingers on a hand and implicitly foregoes advocacy for civil and political rights and instead encourages black Americans to cast down their buckets where they were. and don't worry about how their rights are being systematically denied them in the South.
然后是《迪克西》。成千上万的人正注视着这个即将向南方白人观众发表讲话的黑人，这在那个国家的那个地区可能从未发生过。他于1895年发表了这篇著名或声名狼藉的演讲，他在其中表示，黑人和白人美国人可以像手掌上的手指那样各自独立，并且含蓄地放弃了对民权和政治权利的诉求，转而鼓励美国人“把水桶扔在你所在的地方”，
A reporter who was there wrote it up for the New York world, and he replays this moment where Washington lifts up his hand, his hand representing society. He spreads his fingers apart and says to the audience, in all things purely social, we can be as separate as fingers on a hand. As in white people and black people don't need to mix. We can stay segregated and still work towards the same goal. It was a simple and effective metaphor for the fiction of separate but equal.
不用担心他们在南方被系统性地剥夺了权利。一位当时在场的记者为《纽约世界报》撰文报道了此事，他重现了这样一个时刻：华盛顿举起他的手，他的手代表着社会。他将手指叉开，对观众说，在所有纯粹的社会事务中，我们可以像手上的手指一样各自独立。意思是白人和黑人不需要融合。我们可以保持隔离，却依然朝着同一个目标努力。对于“隔离但平等”的虚伪性来说，这是一个简单而有效的隐喻。
And white America loved it. It gave them exactly what they wanted. The comfort of segregation without the guilt. Social separation without moral responsibility. And the crowd goes into what the reporter calls a delirium of applause. Hats in the air. Handkerchiefs waving. Everyone on their feet.
而白人美国人对此喜爱有加。它给了他们梦寐以求的东西。没有负罪感的隔离之安逸。没有道德责任的社会隔离。人群爆发出记者所谓的“狂热的掌声”。帽子抛向空中。手帕在挥舞。所有人起立。
The speech is a rousing success in mainstream America because in many ways, you know, it's 1895, so it's some years past the end of reconstruction, which completely ended by 1877. But in the intervening years, Jim Crow is becoming more deeply entrenched in the U.S. South and really in many ways across the country. And by that I mean not just segregated facilities, but also segregated forms of employment, really control of the labor of African Americans. The beginning of we see sort of fundamentally unequals experiences with relationship to law enforcement and the like. And so it is a speech that has this sort of mythology to it that if black Americans just were, really hard and put their heads down and stop pushing against the way the society is becoming increasingly more oppressive and restrictive, then things will get better. And it not only lets the South off the hook, but it lets the federal government off the hook, which is, in some
这篇演讲在主流美国社会取得了巨大的成功，因为在许多方面，你知道的，那是1895年，距离重建期结束已经过去了好几年（重建期在1877年彻底结束）。但在随后的几年里，吉姆·克劳法在美国南方以及实际上在全国许多地方变得根深蒂固。我的意思不仅是隔离的设施，还有隔离的就业形式，以及对非洲裔美国人劳动的实际控制。我们开始看到与执法部门等等相关的根本不平等的经历。因此，这篇演讲带有某种神话色彩，仿佛如果美国黑人只是非常努力地工作，低头做事，停止反抗日益压迫和限制的社会，那么事情就会变好。这不仅让南方卸下了责任，也让联邦政府卸下了责任，在某些
ways, has already abandoned African Americans in the advocacy for the rights that they were granted after the Civil War. You might have learned about this speech in school. It becomes known as the Atlanta compromise, because compromise is what many people hear in it, whether or not that's all Washington intended. I mean, it absolutely didn't represent the totality of Washington's thought, and he's certainly in many covert ways advocated for organizations that supported civil and political rights for African Americans. There's no question that he was maneuvering politically in public. and behaving differently in private. The speech makes Washington a national figure.
方面，联邦政府已经抛弃了为非洲裔美国人争取他们在内战后被赋予的权利。你可能在学校里学过这篇演讲。它被称为“亚特兰大妥协”，因为妥协是许多人在其中听到的东西，不管这是否是华盛顿的全部意图。我的意思是，它绝对不代表华盛顿思想的全部，而且他在许多隐蔽的方式中确实支持了那些支持非洲裔美国人公民和政治权利的组织。毫无疑问，他在公众面前进行政治操纵，
Practically overnight, he becomes the most powerful black man in the United States. But it also opens a kind of schism. And Washington is about to meet an opponent who would challenge him over what freedom should look like. Someone unwilling to compromise. Someone ready to fight. Bookerty Washington's ideas about black education are about to meet their challenger, another intellectual heavyweight named W.E.B. Du Bois also has a philosophy whose origins can be traced back to the blue back speller. Only his experience with the book comes much later in life,
而在私底下表现得则不尽相同。这篇演讲让华盛顿成为了一个全国性人物。几乎在一夜之间，他成为了美国最有权势的黑人。但这也开启了一种分裂。而华盛顿即将迎来一位挑战者，向他质疑自由应当是什么样子。一个不愿妥协的人。一个随时准备战斗的人。布克·T·华盛顿关于黑人教育的思想即将迎来挑战者，另一位知识界重量级人物——W·E·B·杜波依斯，他的哲学渊源也可以追溯到那本蓝皮拼写书。只是他与这本书的经历要晚得多，
because Du Bois is born into a much different world than Booker T. Washington. Well, I want to bring in another historic figure, young W.E.B. De Bois. He reads this speech after it gets published. Where is De Bois in his life at this point, a little bit of his upbringing and how he sort of becomes an educator. Yeah, so part of what's really interesting about Du Bois is he and Washington are often positioned at odds, as they were. But it's important to remember that, you know, Washington is sort of almost two decades older than Du Bois.
因为杜波依斯出生在一个与布克·T·华盛顿截然不同的世界里。嗯，我想引入另一位历史人物，年轻的W·E·B·杜波依斯。他在该演讲发表后阅读了它。杜波依斯此时的人生处于什么阶段，他的成长经历是怎样的，他是如何成为一名教育家的？是的，所以关于杜波依斯，一个非常有趣的地方在于，他和华盛顿经常被置于对立的位置，他们也确实如此。但重要的是要记住，你知道的，华盛顿比杜波依斯大约年长近二十岁。
It's actually only 12 years that separate Washington and Du Bois. But those dozen years between slavery and not slavery are a seismic shift. Washington, you know, is born in slavery. Du Bois is born in Great Barrington, Massachusetts, and has a very different kind of coming of age. You know, doesn't have to walk 500 miles to get to school. And he is, you know, well-educated, a member of a very small black community in the Berkshires where he's aware of being different and made aware in elementary school when he tries to give a Valentine to a little girl who rejects it. And this becomes his moment of racial awareness, a racial reckoning. But understood is extremely bright and talented.
实际上，分隔华盛顿和杜波依斯的只有12年。但这奴隶制与非奴隶制之间的短短十二年，却是一次翻天覆地的转变。你知道的，华盛顿出生于奴隶制。杜波依斯出生在马萨诸塞州的大巴灵顿，经历了一种非常不同的成长过程。你知道的，他不需要走500英里去上学。而且他，你知道的，受过良好教育，是伯克希尔地区一个非常小的黑人社区的成员。在那里，他意识到自己的不同，并在小学时尝试向一个小女孩送情人节卡片却遭到拒绝时，意识到了这一点。这成为了他种族意识觉醒、种族清算的时刻。但他被认为极其聪颖且有才华。
And when he graduates from high school, his mother dies when he's 17. And so members of the local community put money together and sent him to Fisk University, which is the School of Classical Education for African Americans at the time in Nashville. He wanted to go to Harvard undergraduate. He winds up at Fisk. And Fisk is an extraordinary experience for him. It's an outstanding institution. And also for him the first time, he's around large numbers of African Americans.
当他高中毕业时，他17岁时母亲去世了。于是当地社区的成员凑钱把他送到了菲斯克大学，那是当时纳什维尔专门为非洲裔美国人提供古典教育的学校。他原本想去哈佛读本科。最后他来到了菲斯克。菲斯克对他来说是一段非凡的经历。这是一个杰出的机构。而且这也是他生平第一次身处大量非洲裔美国人之中。
And these are really people who are amongst, you know, the best and brightest at that moment. He's at Fisk. And in the summer after his sophomore year, as many students at historically black colleges at the time do, he finds a school to teach at during the summer. This was a sort of routine process. And so if we say in Nashville in general, he learns about what Jim Crow looks like, great, a comprehensive system of segregation,
这些人确实是当时最优秀、最聪颖的人才之一。他在菲斯克。在大二之后的那个夏天，正如当时许多历史悠久的黑人高校的学生所做的那样，他找了一所学校在夏天教书。这是一个常规的过程。如果我们泛指在纳什维尔，他了解到了吉姆·克劳法是什么样子的，太棒了，一个全面的隔离系统，
very different from the kind of racism that he experienced in Great Barrington. So once Fisk is this remarkable place that he falls in love with and also the place where he really understands what life is like for the majority. of African Americans. So it's one level, but Nashville is a city.
这与他在大巴灵顿经历的那种种族主义截然不同。所以一旦菲斯克成为一个让他坠入爱河的非凡地方，同时也是他真正理解大多数非洲裔美国人生活的地方。所以这是一个层面，但纳什维尔是一座城市。
You know, in the summer, he goes out to rural Tennessee. Very different kind of landscape. People are really living at a subsistence level. And it is here in this rural village that Du Bois will have a transformative experience with the Blue Black Speller as a young teacher with a room full of black children in front of him. And he teaches at this school and he talks about, beautiful children with these bright and curious minds and he describes them sitting in front of the blue-back speller
你知道的，到了夏天，他去了田纳西州的农村。那是截然不同的风景。人们确实过着勉强维生水平的生活。正是在这个乡村小村庄里，杜波依斯将作为一名年轻的教师，面对满屋子的黑人儿童，与这本蓝皮拼写书产生具有变革意义的经历。他在那所学校教书，他谈到了那些有着明亮而好奇的心灵的美丽孩子们，他描述他们坐在蓝皮拼写书前，
and teaching them. Years later, Du Bois writes about those students. They're bright but mischievous faces, bare feet swinging from rough benches, hands wrapped around the speller. And he writes about encountering these students and how extraordinary they are and how they're learning in a context
他教导他们。多年后，杜波依斯写到了那些学生。他们聪明但调皮的面孔，赤脚从粗糙的长凳上晃荡着，双 紧紧握着拼写书。他写到了与这些学生相遇的经历，以及他们是多么非凡，以及他们如何在这样一个国家本应致力于这种进步、但黑人却在被拖后腿的语境下学习。多年后，他重返那所学校，却发现他最珍爱的学生乔西已经去世了。昔日的许多希望也已熄灭。
where the nation is supposed to be engaged in this progress, but black people are being held back. And then many years later, he returns to the school and finds that his prized pupil Josie has died. And so much of the promise has been snuffed out. De Bois doesn't actually say how Josie dies, but in the intervening years, her family has fallen apart. a brother in jail, a sister returning home with a child,
杜波依斯其实并没有说明乔西是怎么死的，但在随后的几年里，她的家庭分崩离析了：一个兄弟锒铛入狱，一个妹妹带着孩子回到家中，
and Josie carrying the weight of all of it, working, working, working herself to death. And that loss clarifies something for Du Bois. This story in some ways encapsulates why he becomes so resistant to his elder scholar, Booker T. Washington. Because what he shows is that even with all of the hard work, all of the possibility, all of the intellect and imagination, the brutality of the Jim Crow order is such that it destroys people's lives and without access to suffrage, without access
而乔西则独自扛起这一切的重担，劳作、劳作、劳作，最终累死。这种失去为杜波依斯澄清了一些事情。这个故事在某些方面概括了他为什么会如此抵制他的学者前辈布克·T·华盛顿。因为这表明，即便付出了所有的辛勤工作、所有的可能性、所有的才智与想象力，吉姆·克劳秩序的残酷性依然会摧毁人们的生活，如果没有获得选举权、没有获得
to full civil and political rights, no matter how hard you work, you're going to wind up with these devastating consequences. To DeBois, this idea that Washington has, that economic progress and hard work will lead to racial equality just isn't real. And Josie is a lot of proof of that. He understands to a certain extent what Washington is trying to do, but he finds his acceptance of the constraints of Jim Crow unacceptable given the consequences of those constraints. He channels all of this into a scathing critique of Bookerty, Washington, in a chapter of the Souls of Black Folk, published in 1903. So he, you know, this is a really bold thing. he does to write this book and to have this public criticism of, you know, this divide.
充分的公民和政治权利，无论你多么努力工作，你最终都将面临这些毁灭性的后果。在杜波依斯看来，华盛顿的那个“经济进步和努力工作将带来种族平等”的想法根本不切实际。而乔西就是这方面的诸多证明。他在一定程度上理解华盛顿试图做什么，但鉴于这些限制所带来的后果，他认为华盛顿对吉姆·克劳法束缚的接受是不可接受的。他将这一切倾注在对布克·T·华盛顿的尖锐批判中，收录在1903年出版的《黑人的灵魂》中的一章里。所以他，你知道的，写这本书并公开批评这种分歧，这是一件非常大胆的事。
Yeah. I mean, you know, Du Bois, he has a chapter in the Souls of Black Folk called of Mr. Booker T. Washington and others, and he has a very direct and unflinching critique of Washington. In some ways, his personal reflections are a bit gentler than what he publishes. But I think what he's trying to do is give voice to what a little. a lot of black intellectuals and activists and organizers are saying, which is what Washington is saying cannot be seen as speaking for black people writ large, and certainly not the black leadership class, as it were.
是的。我的意思是，你知道的，杜波依斯在《黑人的灵魂》中有一章名为《论布克·T·华盛顿及其他人》，他对华盛顿进行了非常直接且毫不退缩的批判。在某些方面，他的个人反思比他出版的内容要温和一些。但我认为他试图做的是，为许多黑人知识分子、活动家和组织者正在说的话发出声音，那就是：华盛顿所说的话不能被视为代表了广大黑人群体，当然更不能代表所谓的黑人领导阶层。
I think you can sum up DeBoise's critique like this. He believes that Booker T. Washington, by encouraging black Americans to just focus on their own skills and financial independence and to wait for civil rights, to go slow, that Washington is asking them to surrender something fundamental. Their self-respect. For Du Bois, the fight for civil rights and the vote cannot be pushed off into the future. How can someone defend his rights as a landowner or a business owner if he has no political power to do so? And he thinks Washington's focus on industrial education is part of the problem. Instead of practical skills. Du Bois thinks that education for black Americans should be broader, a classical education,
我认为你可以这样总结杜波依斯的批判：他认为布克·T·华盛顿通过鼓励美国黑人只关注他们自己的技能和经济独立、等待民权、放慢脚步，是在要求他们放弃一些根本的东西：他们的自尊。对杜波依斯而言，争取民权和投票权的斗争不能被推迟到未来。如果一个人没有政治权力来捍卫自己的权利，他又如何能捍卫自己作为土地所有者或企业主的权利呢？他认为华盛顿对实业教育的聚焦是问题的一部分。杜波依斯认为，黑人接受的教育不应该局限于实用技能，而应该更广泛，包括古典教育、
Greek, Latin, literature, philosophy, the kinds of subjects that could train a class of black scholars, writers, and leaders. He called this idea, the talented tenth. Du Bois gets a lot of criticism for his concept of the talented tenth that is also in that book in which he says, essentially, you know, there's 10% of any community that are going to function as the leadership class and those people in the black community should have access to, you know, the highest level of education and classical education in particular. And on the one hand, while I think some of the critique is understandable, I think given the context, it's important to keep in mind that if in general in the society people were saying, you know, black people should only have access to industrial education, which really was the norm, he's saying, this, at least 10% of the black population should have access to higher order education. Because if not, then who is going to be in the rooms with white elites to advocate for black
希腊语、拉丁语、文学、哲学，这些能够培养出一阶层黑人学者、作家和领袖的学科。他称这个想法为“十分之一精英”。杜波依斯因为他在那本书中提出的“十分之一精英”概念而受到了很多批评，他在书中本质上说，你知道的，任何社区中都有10%的人将充当领导阶层，黑人社区中的那些人应该有机会获得，你知道的，最高水平的教育，特别是古典教育。一方面，虽然我认为其中一些批评是可以理解的，但我认为鉴于当时的背景，重要的是要记住，如果在整个社会中人们普遍认为（这确实是常态）黑人应该只能接受实业教育，而他说，至少这10%的黑人人口应该有机会接受更高阶的教育。因为如果不是这样，那谁将进入白人精英的房间去为黑人发声呢？
people, right? And so it sounds elitist, and in some ways it was, you know, in Du Bois, I think we can say in some ways was an elitist, but he's really trying to say we should not exclude black people writ large from any sector of the society. And that was a bold statement. Du Bois also thinks there are consequences to Washington's accommodationist beliefs. He sees a direct line between the Atlanta Compromise speech and what came after. Just a year after Washington announced that the races could be as separate as fingers on a hand, the Supreme Court ruled in Plessy v. Ferguson, making separate but equal the law of the land.
所以这听起来很精英主义，在某些方面它也确实是，你知道的，杜波依斯，我想我们可以说在某些方面是个精英主义者，但他真正想说的是，我们不应该将黑人广义地排除在社会的任何部门之外。这是一个大胆的声明。杜波依斯还认为，华盛顿的迁就主义信念会带来后果。他在《亚特兰大妥协》演讲与之后的事情之间看到了直接的联系。就在华盛顿宣布种族可以像手上的手指一样各自独立的仅仅一年后，最高法院在“普莱西诉弗格森案”中作出裁决，使“隔离但平等”成为了土地上的法律。
Du Bois thinks that Washington and the Atlantic compromise speech gives up something that he had no right to give up, right? And sort of presented it as though black Americans were willing to accommodate exclusion. And therefore that that was sort of allowed for Plessy versus Ferguson to be decided without any anxiety on the part of the court. Now, I think the reality is that regardless of what Washington had said, Plessy would likely have been decided the way that it was, I think a better argument would be that Washington, you know, saw the way the wind was blowing and sort of said what he needed to say in order to continue to get financial support given the way the society was turning. When Du Bois publishes the souls of black folk in 1903, it lands. Hard. The book is reprinted twice in its first two months. In some ways, it helps cement a certain kind of legacy for Booker T. Washington,
杜波依斯认为，华盛顿和亚特兰大妥协演讲放弃了他无权放弃的东西，对吧？并且把它表现得好像美国黑人愿意容忍排斥一样。因此，这使得“普莱西诉弗格森案”得以在法院没有任何焦虑的情况下作出裁决。现在，我认为现实是，无论华盛顿说过什么，普莱西案很可能还是会按那样裁决；我认为更好的论点是，华盛顿，你知道的，看清了风向，为了鉴于社会的转向而继续获得财政支持，说出了他需要说的话。当杜波依斯于1903年出版《黑人的灵魂》时，它产生了轰动。反响强烈。这本书在头两个月里重印了两次。在某些方面，它帮助巩固了布克·T·华盛顿某种特定的历史遗产，
who is mostly remembered for his accommodationism. But Amani says he's actually much more complicated than that, because of what he's doing behind the scenes with money he got from white donors, particularly when it comes to public education for black people, children in the Jim Crow South. So black students have fewer schools to attend. They often have shorter school terms, and they get much less money than schools for white students.
华盛顿主要因其迁就主义而被人们铭记。但阿马尼说，其实他要复杂得多，因为他在幕后利用从白人捐赠者那里获得的资金做了很多事，特别是在为吉姆·克劳时期的南方黑人儿童提供公立教育方面。因此，黑人学生可供上学的学校较少。他们的学期通常较短，而且他们获得的资金远少于白人学校。
Many places, particularly rural places, don't have access to public schools at all. And southern states do not require schools that have been slated for white students to admit black students, even if they don't have an access to a local school. And it's sort of a long-winded way of getting to the point, which is that Booker T. Washington initiates a school building program with the support of Julius Rosenwald. Julius Rosenwald had built his fortune as president of Sears Roebuck and Company. By the early 1900s, he was one of the wealthiest men in America. And what that means is that they are actually physically building schools across the South for black people to have. attend. And this is transformative, right? And once the schools are built within a generation,
许多地方，尤其是农村地区，根本无法接触到公立学校。南方各州不要求为白人学生预留的学校录取黑人学生，即便他们无法去当地的学校上学。这其实是兜了个大圈子才说到重点，也就是布克·T·华盛顿在朱利叶斯·罗森沃尔德的支持下发起了一项学校建设计划。朱利叶斯·罗森沃尔德作为西尔斯-罗巴克公司的总裁积累了巨额财富。到20世纪初，他是美国最富有的人之一。这意味着他们实际上是在南方各地为黑人兴建学校，让他们有学可上。这具有变革性的意义，对吧？一旦学校建成，在短短一代人的时间内，
the literacy gap is closed between black and white children. So Washington is complicated, because on the one hand, he's known for his accommodationist posture, his willingness to forego advocacy of civil and political rights for African Americans. But on the other hand, he is centrally responsible for for the access to education for African Americans across the South. I mean, it strikes me, like, I don't want to reduce the works of two great men to just, like, basic psychology. But it seems like both of them are saying that the path of black liberation is my path. You know, like, both of them are saying that in their own ways, you know? I mean, and I think that's sort of, you know, these people who become extraordinary leaders have to have unbelievable.
黑人儿童与白人儿童之间的读写差距正在缩小。所以华盛顿的情况很复杂，一方面，他以其妥协的姿态而闻名，他愿意放弃为非裔美国人争取民权和政治权利的主张。但另一方面，他对整个南方非裔美国人获得教育机会负有核心责任。我的意思是，这给我的感觉是，我不想把两个伟大人物的著作仅仅简化为基础心理学。但似乎他们两个都在说，黑人解放的道路就是我的道路。你知道的，就好像他们俩都以各自的方式在表达这一点，你知道吗？我的意思是，我认为这有点像，你知道，这些成为非凡领袖的人必须具备令人难以置信的信念。
conviction. And if you think, one way to think about this is Washington, you know, right before he dies, he dies at age 59. He has a nervous breakdown. He's been carrying such extraordinary burdens trying to sustain Tuskegee and trying to advocate in his own way for black freedom. And one of the challenges was, is that, you know, after that Atlanta compromise speech, many people misinterpreted him as saying that black people should never have access to civil rights. And even in that moment, he was just saying, we'll go a kind of go slow agenda. And so there are people who were angry at him once he said, okay, well, now is the time to start to move towards access to civil and political rights. So he was a man who carried a great deal of stress.
信念。如果你去想的话，有一种看待这件事的方式就是华盛顿，你知道，就在他去世前不久，他于59岁去世。他神经衰竭了。他承担着如此巨大的负担，试图维持塔斯kegee（塔斯基吉）的运转，并以他自己的方式为黑人自由发声。其中一个挑战是，你知道的，在那次亚特兰大妥协演讲之后，许多人误解了他的意思，以为他在说黑人永远不应该获得民权。甚至在那个时刻，他其实只是在说，我们将采取一种循序渐进的议程。因此，一旦他说“好吧，现在是时候开始朝着获得民权和政治权利迈进”，就会有人对他感到愤怒。所以他是一个承受了巨大压力的男人。
And Du Bois, likewise, you know, experienced. He had his passport taken away. He was penniless at various times of his life because of retaliation for his politics. So these people endured so much stress. And in order to endure that kind of stress, I think they had to have an incredible courage of conviction. Part of what I think, though, is interesting about them is that besides their shared conviction, right, even though they had very different agendas, they also shared a real serious. interest in black education, which was really something that, you know, in the early 20th century, black intellectuals across the board were centrally interested in educational issues and not just,
而杜波依斯同样，你知道，也经历过这些。他的护照被没收了。由于他的政治立场遭到报复，他在生活中的不同时期身无分文。因此，这些人忍受了如此巨大的压力。为了忍受那种压力，我认为他们必须具备令人难以置信的坚定信念。不过，我认为他们有趣的一部分在于，除了他们共同的信念之外，即使他们有着截然不同的议程，他们也对黑人教育有着真正严肃的兴趣。这在20世纪初是这样的，你知道的，各行各业的黑人知识分子都核心关注教育问题，而不仅仅是
you know, higher education, but K-12 education, education of kids was seen as a central concern. And so even in the midst of their debate, they're trying to think about how do we prepare children for a world for a future that does not yet exist but a future that they deserve. And that shared conviction is something that I think of as pretty remarkable for men of that stature. I mean, it's almost as like Du Bois's, you know, born, you know, a generation later in a different environment. If he's not doing, like if kids aren't freaking me out, then kids aren't doing their job.
你知道，高等教育，还有K-12教育，儿童教育被视为一个核心关注点。因此，即使在他们的辩论中，他们也在试图思考我们如何为孩子们准备一个尚不存在的世界、一个尚未到来的未来，但这是一个他们应得的未来。这种共同的信念在我看来对那个地位的男人们来说是非常了不起的。我的意思是，这几乎就像杜波依斯，你知道的，在不同的环境中晚了一代人出生。如果孩子们没有让我抓狂，那就说明孩子们没有在做好他们的工作。
Like, you know what I mean? Like if kids aren't like advocating for something different, like that's what progress is. That's the point of progress. That's as natural as anything. I agree with that. But, you know, even today, right, young people start to push for things outside of the conventions of, you know, mainstream politics. And older people like, you know, get really rough on young people who are bringing in new ideas and unwilling to just go along. There's a lot to learn from that story.
就像，你知道我的意思吗？就像如果孩子们没有在为某些不同的东西大声疾呼，这就是进步。这就是进步的意义。那是再自然不过的事情了。我同意这一点。但是，你知道，即使在今天，年轻人也开始推动主流政治常规之外的事情。而年长者，你知道的，对待那些带来新思想且不愿随波逐流的年轻人时会变得非常严厉。从那个故事中有很多东西可以学习，
if we're willing to really pay attention to things like what you just said, that young people are bringing in new ideas. Yeah, that's their job, as far as I'm concerned. Like, that they have one job. It's to continue progress. It's worth noting that Du Bois continued to sort of push very hard at the limits of black politics all the way until his death in 1963, you know, and is frequently on the outs with those who are most powerful. Yeah, so much so that he ends up in Africa and everything. He ends up in exile in Ghana at the end of his life. Yeah.
如果我们愿意真正去关注诸如你刚才所说的事情，即年轻人正在带来新的思想。是的，就我而言，那是他们的工作。就像他们只有一份工作一样。那就是延续进步。值得一提的是，杜波依斯一直坚持不懈地推动黑人政治的极限，直到他在1963年去世，你知道的，并且经常与那些最有权势的人意见相左。是的，甚至到了他最终去到非洲等地的地步。他在晚年流亡加纳。是的。
He's a pan-Africanist. He's a socialist. He, you know, one of the founders, first of the Niagara movement, which is the precursor to the NAACP, one of the founders of the NAACP, the first editor of the NACP organ, the crisis. And the NACP is a multiracial civil rights organization and national. initially. And he pushes that organization so hard at various moments that he is repeatedly fired and then brought back in. And at times it's because, you know, of his position where he becomes a very assertive pan-Africanist, at times because of his positions on capitalism.
他是一位泛非主义者。他是一位社会主义者。他，你知道的，是尼亚加拉运动的第一批创始人之一，该运动是全国有色人种协进会（NAACP）的前身，也是全国有色人种协进会的创始人和第一任编辑，该组织名为《危机》。起初，全国有色人种协进会是一个多元种族的民权和全国性组织。在不同的时刻，他极力推动这个组织，以至于他多次被解雇又被重新录用。有时是因为，你知道的，他的立场使他成了一个非常坚定自信的泛非主义者，有时则是因为他在资本主义问题上的立场。
At times it's because he is, he's just so outspoken about American racism. And so, that he takes on Washington as a young man in some ways is an indication of who he will be over the course of the rest of his life. So I want to get back to this, the blueback speller, in many ways, was the initial seed for black formal education. What does it mean that the same object was the route for both Booker T. Washington and for W.E.B. DeBoise's sort of intellectual formation. Yeah, I mean, I, you know, I'm so taken. by the fact that the same object, it's Booker T. Washington and W.E.B. Du Bois for whom the blueback speller matters. It's also Frederick Douglass, you know, like most famous abolitionist.
有时是因为他，他对美国的种族主义直言不讳。因此，他在年轻时就敢于挑战华盛顿，在某种程度上预示了他余生将成为什么样的人。所以我想回到这个话题，蓝色拼写课本在很多方面是黑人正规教育的最初种子。同样的对象对于布克·T·华盛顿和W·E·B·杜波依斯的知识形成过程而言意味着什么。是的，我的意思是，我，你知道的，我被这样一个事实深深吸引了，即同一个对象，无论是对于布克·T·华盛顿还是W·E·B·杜波依斯，蓝色拼写课本都很重要。这也是弗雷德里克·道格拉斯的经历，你知道的，就像最著名的废奴主义者一样。
Also George Washington Carver, this brilliant scientist and artist who does all this transformative work at Tuskegee and also like really saves the land in Alabama after it has been. so destroyed by the cotton economy with crop rotation techniques, they all start with this book. It's a really interesting story about what access can do, right? So that just access to literacy, having a tool to access literacy, opens up these worlds for these extraordinary thinkers, right, who might otherwise not have had that kind of access. It also says something about the power of the intellect and the depth of their convictions to be learned people who do meaningful work, right? So that holding this book close tells you something about their character and tells you something about resiliency. And I
还有乔治·华盛顿·卡弗，这位杰出的科学家和艺术家，他在塔斯基吉做了所有这些具有变革性的工作，并且在阿拉巴马州的土地被棉花经济的轮作技术严重破坏后，真正拯救了这片土地，他们都是从这本书开始的。这是一个非常有趣的故事，关于获取机会能带来什么，对吧？因此，仅仅是获得读写能力，拥有一个获取读写能力的工具，就为这些杰出的思想家打开了这些世界，否则他们可能不会有那种机会。它也说明了智力的力量和他们坚定信念的深度，使他们成为能够做有意义工作的有学问的人，对吧？因此，珍视这本书说明了他们的品格，也说明了坚韧。而我
get very emotional and inspired, you know, reflecting on what it meant to, you know, carry this book in one's pocket and that being understood as the key to personal transformation, but also community-wide social transformation. And so I think that word key is really significant because it's not just a key for people to learn to read, but it is a key, I think, for us to understand something about the building of the African-American intellectual and political tradition. That gets to something bigger, because this isn't about a book anymore. It's about what people can do with a tool once they claim it for themselves. There's something quintessentially American about the blueback speller. You know, what more
在反思在口袋里揣着这本书意味着什么时，会变得非常感性和受到鼓舞，这被理解为个人转变的关键，也是整个社区社会转变的关键。因此，我认为“关键”这个词非常重要，因为它不仅是人们学习阅读的关键，而且我认为它也是我们理解非裔美国人知识和政治传统构建的关键。这触及了一个更宏大的问题，因为这不再只关乎一本书。这关乎人们一旦将工具据为己有，能用它做些什么。蓝色拼写课本中有一种极其典型的美国特色。你知道的，还有什么比
kind of democratic instrument than an object that you can use to make yourself literate and it opens up this world of possibility? But it's also quintessentially American in the sense that its creator, Noah Webster, did not consider Black Americans as part of the American project. That's also quintessentially American. And then the other layer of something as quintessentially American is black Americans taking that which is not intended for us and reinterpreting it in a way that not only includes Black Americans, but actually then becomes something different in the hands of Black Americans, right? It becomes not only a way to learn to read, but actually a tool for entry into all kinds of arenas where they had not been contemplated.
一种可以用来让自己识字并打开充满可能性的世界的工具更具民主色彩的乐器呢？但从其创造者诺亚·韦伯斯特不认为美洲黑人是美国宏伟蓝图的一部分这一意义上讲，这也是极其典型的美国特色。这也是极其典型的美国特色。然后另一层的典型美国特色是，美洲黑人拿走了原本并非为我们准备的东西，并对其进行重新诠释，使其不仅包含美洲黑人，而且在美洲黑人的手中实际上变成了完全不同的东西，对吧？它不仅成为学习阅读的一种方式，而且实际上成为进入他们以前从未被纳入的各种领域的工具。
No one understood this better than Frederick Douglass, a man who had already done exactly this kind of reinvention with that little blue book. But what Douglas learned to do with the speller, to take something that wasn't meant for him and transform it into something liberating. He would ultimately do that on a much larger scale. Douglas actually does something with what it means to be American that's really profound. You know, when he becomes an abolitionist, most abolitionists at that time really rejected the U.S. Constitution. They said, this is a slaveholding document, so we shouldn't consider it something meaningful. And Douglas says, no, no, let's reinterpret the Constitution.
没有人比弗雷德里克·道格拉斯更懂这一点了，他已经用那本蓝色小册子精确地完成了这种重塑。但是道格拉斯学会用拼写课本做的事情，是把一件不属于他的东西变成解放性的东西。他最终将在更大的规模上做到这一点。道格拉斯对“身为美国人”意味着什么的诠释实际上非常深远。你知道，当他成为一名废奴主义者时，当时大多数废奴主义者实际上拒绝接受美国宪法。他们说，这是一份维护奴隶制的文献，所以我们不应该认为它有什么意义。而道格拉斯说，不，不，让我们重新诠释宪法。
Let's hold on to its principles. And yet interpret it to actually be a document that supports the concept of all men being created equal. And then he says, and actually all human beings created equal, because Douglas is also this sort of foundational feminist. And I think there's an analogy there with the blueback speller. So, you know, here's a society that does not consider black people part of the body politic. Here's a foundational document that does not, not only does not consider black people, but has the racist three-fifths compromise in it. But Douglas reinterprets that document to expand the conception of course. who should be considered American.
让我们坚守其原则，并对其进行诠释，使其真正成为一份支持“人生而平等”概念的文件。然后他说，实际上是所有人类生而平等，因为道格拉斯也是这种奠基性的女权主义者。我认为这与蓝色拼写课本之间存在一种类比。所以，你看，这是一个不把黑人视为政治共同体一部分的社会；这是一个不仅不考虑黑人，而且其中包含种族主义的“五分之三妥协”的奠基文献。但道格拉斯重新诠释了这份文献，以扩大人们对谁应该被视为美国人的理解。
There's something that you get about the American story through the blueback speller that we find repetitions of in all these different kinds of ways that I do think of as a really distinctive part of the Black American story. Thank you so much for talking with me. I just enjoyed it so immensely. Thanks.
通过蓝色拼写课本，你可以领悟到一些关于美国故事的东西，我们在所有这些不同类型的方式中都能发现这些东西的重复，我确实认为这是美洲黑人故事中一个非常独特的组成部分。非常感谢你与我交谈。我非常享受这段对话。谢谢。
It was a great conversation. I appreciate you. Imani Perry is the author of nine books, including the National Book Award-winning New York Times bestseller, South to America. And the inspiration for this episode, Black and Blues, how a color tells the story of my people. In the dry desert of history books, Imani Perry's writing is like a cool sip of water. I cannot recommend her enough. A history of the United States and 100 Objects is a production of 99% Invisible and BBC Studios. It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars.
这是一次很棒的对话。我很感激你。伊马尼·佩里是九本书的作者，其中包括荣获美国国家图书奖的《纽约时报》畅销书《向南到美国》。这也是本期节目的灵感来源，即《布鲁斯与黑人：一种颜色如何讲述我人民的故事》。在历史书干旱的沙漠中，伊马尼·佩里的文字就像是一口清凉的水。我极力向大家推荐她的书。《美国历史与100件物品》是99% Invisible和BBC Studios联合制作的节目。由我罗曼·马尔斯主持和策划。
This episode was produced by Priscilla Al-A-Vee. Our other producers are Ellie Lightfoot and Brenna Dahldorf. Our associate producer is Isaac Fisher. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell, mixing by Charlie Brandon King. Fact-checking by Amy Bracken. Our theme song is by Swan Real. From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2.
本期节目由普里西拉·阿尔-阿维制作。我们的其他制作人是埃利·莱特富特和布雷娜·达尔多夫。我们的助理制作人是艾萨克·费舍尔。本系列由安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔剪辑，混音由查理·布兰登·金完成。事实核查由艾米·布雷肯完成。我们的主题曲由斯旺·里尔创作。来自99% Invisible，我们的执行制片人是凯茜2世。
From BBC studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Our production coordinator is Shan Palet. And the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright, artwork by Stefan Lawrence. 99% Invisible is part of the Serious XM podcast family, headquartered in Beautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California. And BBC Studios is headquartered in beautiful, White City, West London. If you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider, email us at 100 objects at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自BBC Studios，我们的执行制片人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。我们的制作协调员是珊·帕莱特。制作经理是梅贝尔·芬尼根·赖特，插图由斯特凡·劳伦斯绘制。99% Invisible是Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。BBC Studios总部位于伦敦西部美丽的白城。如果您想与我们联系或有物件希望我们考虑，请发送电子邮件至100 objects at 99PI.org。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。